all right Buffy yes Buffy uh where are
you from originally where'd you grow up
I am from a small town in Southern
Michigan 15 minutes from the Ohio border
uh
I was born and raised there and I moved
to Dallas the day after I graduated high
school
with your family no no
um on my own my mom and my stepdad lived
here my sister had moved a year before
maybe two years before
um in my town there wasn't much talk of
college
um
or college or just a future
so I thought growing up I sort of
thought my mom is this grandiose Rich
figure and
um so I thought she'd pay for college so
I came to Dallas to go to college and I
went to a community college he hadn't
set anything up like I thought she had
um so I went to school to be a police
officer for two years
police officer yeah I didn't end up
being a police officer
despite the tattoos I work in Corporate
America I'm the legal field
so I switched wanted to carry a
briefcase and switched from Criminal
Justice to just a general Business
Degree with paralegal focusing on
paralegal studies and I worked 20 about
23 years in Corporate America real
estate law let's go back to your
childhood so tell me about your mom and
dad Okay so
I was the fourth child of two parents
parents who were 23 years old I was the
fourth yeah
um I remember very little of them being
together
but I do remember the day my mom left so
I think I was around two
my mom packed a suitcase we all slept in
the same bed I believe
and I just remember waking up and she
was had a suede coat on with fur down it
in a suitcase holding her suitcase
um I mean looking back that could be the
day she left or it could be an anger
um day when she just left my dad for a
couple days but she left
um and four of us a brother
two sisters older than me we were left
with my dad who was an alcoholic but
Adria I believe I was probably between
two and three by the time she left
um we were going to go to foster homes
before that which is really weird in my
mind but before that my mom lived in the
town next to us on a trail in a trailer
with her boyfriend and we ended up
moving into or at least staying with my
Tia Ray who was my mom's Uncle
um
we stayed with him and I remember waking
up and our eyes just were like shot with
the Sleepy things you get in your eye
nothing was he's he's a priest um
and was married and well I don't know if
you could be a priest and be married but
he was something in the Catholic church
so it wasn't like we had a bad time
there but I remember not being able to
come inside during the day and I
remember peeing my pants those are my
memories there I was probably three
my mom lived on that same property in a
trailer with her abusive boyfriend
I don't really know if like in my mind I
thought
anything of my mom's there and we're not
in the trailer with her
um I know I was very scared of this guy
um
but eventually my mom left to Washington
DC Maryland area
um we were going to go into foster homes
but I guess from what it sounds like my
mom left thinking she left us with a
good guy at least he was a good dad but
he was an alcoholic and what she says is
abuser abuser
um and we never saw the physical abuse
at least that I know of
um
so
we my dad didn't have anywhere to go
um
so I guess it got to the courts and my
dad got custody of us last minute
because my grandparents my dad's parents
said they'd take us so there's a picture
of us all dressed up
looking cute or pretty in her dresses
my brother probably just in some kind of
polo shirt
um
on their back picnic table and I look at
that picture and thank God we just
wanted
to be loved for someone to take us
so
yeah we um
it was a 400 square foot home I've never
had a bed
I slept on the love seat while my
brother slept on the couch and my
grandmother pulled a mattress off her
bed every day and put it on the floor
for my two sisters
and um for some reason one night my
grandparents were gone they went to
Arkansas every so often
and my dad slept in the basement
um
and he had like this TV that sits on the
floor on one of those old school TVs
probably black and white but behind it
was all the 40 ounce bottles that he
could return because we were in Michigan
but there's tons of 40 ounces
um but for some reason that night
um
I woke up
my dad's still around so
I I you know kind of worried about this
but I woke up to
what I felt was like blowing on my
stomach
um I don't I didn't know what it was I
just knew it was wrong
um I remember trying to get out of this
situation by saying I had to go to the
bathroom and he happened to have to go
to the bathroom too
uh I was in my little nightgown and
athletic shorts from church camp
and um
he took me into the bathroom and pulled
my pants down
and just caressed my body the hips that
I hate to this day
um
that kind of did this and I don't know I
everything is so clear to me
the feelings just the wanting to get
away
um
and that lining of my hips sometimes I
can't even look in the mirror
um getting out of a bathtub I don't like
to be naked
but these hips have just come with me
and become a something that I don't like
um
so then to get him away from me I said I
was hot and there was a pull out bed on
the porch and
he happened to be hot too and I guess we
just maybe
maybe he came to his senses
um
and it was over
um I tend to think that wasn't the first
time or there were inappropriate things
other times but
um that's what I remember and my poor
sister
four years older than me I went to her
the next morning and took her in the
only bedroom there and explained it to
her and
she said never tell anybody so
but I'm a talker so I didn't tell
anybody for a long time
um but a couple of years later maybe
three
I ended up telling my grandparents
um and it was
just kind of um
no I don't talk about it
um
I
then I didn't
um kind of confused but we were
continued to be left home there with
them while they were out on
they didn't vacation so I'm not sure
where they would have been but they had
family in Arkansas but we could yell
through the events and my dad could hear
us but just a couple nights after I was
molested my dad
um called me down through the event and
asked me to come down and I
was crying and bawling and didn't want
to go down and nobody knew but my sister
um and she might have been the one that
actually said she would go down he ended
up having eighty dollars for each of us
which I guess was as well for her money
um that he got
um
so yeah that's that's that story
my dad went on to actually go to prison
not for me
um
but he continued to be an alcoholic
before he went to prison I was in charge
of taking care of him so what did he go
to prison for
sexual assault
um I believe aggravated on who I'm just
a neighbor girl of uh he ended up
remarrying a neighbor girl of one of his
stepsons
so that was on my 18th birthday I'd
already know this is somebody a minor
a minor with disabilities
um
I was in the same grade as her brother
I was already graduated by the time and
moved to Texas by the time this that
happened I remember flying back and I
have no idea why thinking maybe I had
friends that would want to hang out with
me
um my theater friends but I remember
calling and everybody seemed to be on
vacation
and
I don't think anybody wanted to talk to
me because in small towns that those
things are in the newspaper my poor
brother has the same name as him
um
but before that before I moved I was in
charge of my dad the one thing has many
laws as he's broken he never broke uh
driving
so he never had a license
um so I would go pick him up after high
school he lived in a trailer with no
electricity and no water
on some guy's land that he sort of
worked for I guess I don't know what he
did
and we would go get him alcohol and then
I would maybe food I don't remember
getting them food
one time we went to get weed and I felt
in my head like oh we've really crossed
the line I was Raising being raised with
my grandparents and drugs and alcohol
none of that were a part of
our household no alcohol my Grandpa
would get mad sometimes and bring home a
beer but he couldn't ever drink it
um
so yeah I just
my dad would be homeless in motels
um the Salvation Army put him up in
motels for a while
um so
I move go back thinking I have friends
and you know nobody I remember that
being the most depressing trip
um I went back again and was
strongly encouraged by my family to go
visit him in prison I made it to the
prison parking lot
and um
I couldn't go in I had a major panic
attack probably my first
um begging people as they were walking
by to go visit
their their people
um
just begging anybody helped me take me
to the hospital give me an ambulance I
was I was freaked out I never knew panic
um
I eventually went in so somebody came
out to get me I remember hearing like
imagine how dad would feel if you don't
go in so I remember going in
a little bit I have a picture I think
um
yeah so I've kept up that
well when he was in prison I'd write him
letters really angry letters
um like telling him he can't spell if he
has all that time in prison wasn't he
learned a spell begging him to just tell
the truth about me
um forget about this other person
who I was on her side by the way
um but just uh tell somebody that I'm
telling the truth
in seventh grade I went to a counselor
and they called CPS and they came to
interview me
a few years later
and I was in um in like a group for kids
that were
not troubled but maybe on the edge
um
uh and I told didn't know that it was a
duty to report and um just had to
give the whole story and it's my truth
so I didn't feel like it was anything
there was any sort of lie um but so I
told it all
and I remember them asking me what word
I would use for
um the vagina and I I remember saying in
a very crude word I don't even know
where I heard it but the very next day
my eye was shamed so much by my family
that I had to go in and tell him I was
lying
and uh
that was the hardest thing because
I felt like if they were proper CPS
workers they could
um see in my face or hearing my story
that I wasn't telling a lie
um
I told them exactly what happened is I'm
telling you now and it's
so believable like how would a how would
a child make that up but I had to I had
to go back and say it was a lie
and I got blamed that my dad actually
drove and
uh yeah so
I never really had any help
um never really had any toys any books
any anybody to keep me safe from the
Boogeyman and the Boogeyman was in my
basement
um
terrified at night to go to sleep almost
still to this day
um
but
I cut off my relationship with my dad
this past year at the end of last year
just decided
it wasn't I didn't need to be
um with him or
I didn't need to have a relationship
with him
um it was incredibly forgiving of me too
and I thought I forgave him
until
my life started to fall apart and I
realized that that one act of sexual
assault
um I blame that for everything that's
followed
um to this day
my mom's abandonment my mom's drug use
the fact that we could never find my mom
Mother's Day cards would be sent back
we'd try to call her and the numbers
would be disconnected anytime she'd
visit
just maybe once a year she'd have a
different guy almost all of that stuff I
put to the side and I'm so pissed off
that I was molested
and I'm so pissed off that I'm still to
this day fearful and angry and unlovable
not worthy
um there were three options that night
for my dad to choose and he chose me
and throughout my life I sort of see a
victim
um
kind of I mean become the victim in many
men's stories
nothing to to that extreme but just
always the person that's being
victimized and
I I don't know if that's what caused an
internal hate Within Myself
um
but
I I have no hope
to this day or
I
in my notes on my phone you'll find
different
notes to family because I don't want to
wake up the next day
I don't have purpose I haven't had love
romantic love I go years without hearing
I love you
I have a son who's 17.
uh and that's the relationship that I
keep most dear or the only relationship
my family doesn't say I love you I do
have sisters and a brother and a mom and
a dad we don't use those words
uh but I'm missing what a lot of people
have when they come home is somebody to
share life with and
I think that it's that I'm the problem
um
my looks my personality
maybe I would be horrible to be around
I think No One's Gonna like my body and
my face
I have wanted to scratch my neck up so
bad that like they'd have to do plastic
surgery
to fix it
um
I don't know what's so wrong with me
but it follows me
I have no idea
um I can come into
a place I can see
I'm tall I can see people looking at me
but it's always in my mind it's negative
what are they thinking about me or my
Tattoo's offensive is my neck offensive
is my face offensive it's never oh they
might think I'm pretty
um or my style might be great
um
but
I don't care to hear all that I don't
need reassurance I know what I look like
but I would I do need love and I want
love
and I don't understand why I'm not
deserving of it
except that my mom didn't give it to me
my dad gave it to me the wrong way
um
just imagine
being at home and
working from home
and weeks go by
without anybody saying
Years Ago by without anybody saying I
love you but weeks go by without people
checking in besides my group text of my
sisters and my mom
um I feel like my life's a waste I'm I'm
sitting there and
I missed all of spring
um
and that's the best time in Texas where
it's 70 degrees or 80 degrees
um I missed it all because I was home
inside
um
I my son luckily drives and um
that's how food is delivered to me
I've now discovered ubereats but that's
a little expensive so
he actually when he's with his dad which
is every other week
he checks in on me and brings me food
sometimes
sometimes I just won't eat
um so I don't have to go anywhere
and when you're depressed you don't
necessarily taking care of yourself so
going to the store isn't just let me
slip on my shoes and go to the store
it's let me
start from scratch and take the bath
that I haven't taken for a week and
change my clothes
um wash my hair
so it's not just an it's not just get
out and go
sometimes
I do get the urge to go out I'm I love
music
like nothing other music that freaked me
out when I was a kid and my dad would
have us at House parties and and the
classical class I'm sorry classic rock
music that I hated I'm obsessed with now
um
so I do get the urge to go out and every
once in a while I do and when I do I get
dressed up and I I put on makeup and
um I love fashion so I I go out have a
really good time and then when I get
back home
I'm like oh yeah another night where no
one
I don't go out for the attention but
it's so easy to realize
there's no attention there's nobody
um
I mean the the only times I think I
would find somebody is if I'm out and if
you don't find anybody there no one's
coming to my apartment to knock on the
door
um
we're living without love
is almost unlivable it's almost it's not
doable
um having no passions no hobbies and I
can draw I can style I can do these
things but when you're depressed that
all goes away or you forget you have
those or sometimes I can draw and then
I'll pick up a pen and I can't draw
so I don't know what happens then but
then it'll keep me away from my hobbies
um sometimes I like to read other times
I can't concentrate
um
mostly I just don't see an end I don't
see a positive end for my life
I don't see a living
for a long time whether that's and I
don't plan to take my life I have a son
and I don't want to leave that Legacy
and I don't want to be what my mom is
and I don't want to abandon
so I won't do that
um but I will I don't do not believe in
God
um I think I had some religious trauma
growing up
um but I'll pray to anyone at night
just make up the last night make it look
like an accident or give me an accident
stage something where I just don't have
to keep going
um
yeah so
I don't know what's gonna happen to me I
I'd like to say I'll keep going keep
plugging along and maybe seeing what's
out there
um
I don't see a change for my job I'm in
the highest that I can be for my level I
didn't go to the law school so that
would be the next level
um I don't see finding a great love
I know a lot of people are doing stuff
online and I just don't have an interest
um because I think I'll be a
disappointment once I show up for the
date
and rejection when you're so used to
being rejected is not something that you
go out and seek
so
I don't know
um yes I've been to therapy I went to
treatment at the end of last year
for a week
for a week for 30 days and then 30 days
of Outpatient Treatment
while it was great everything was great
while you're in there you come out and
life is there for you nothing changed
you know you just come back and It's
never enough time I feel I feel like it
should be a year-long process but um so
yeah I've had treatment I just can't
seem to stick to any of these things
that they tell you to do
they don't come to mind also like when
you're supposed to wake up and feel Joy
like I don't that doesn't come to mind I
just wake up and start going like I
don't stop to process
and I've been a meditator before had a
Buddhist phase
so all of this stuff I know it's just it
must be so down in there and the pain is
so here
the pain is all here
um
in it's overwhelming
and
I hope one day
to find a partner
and I don't want to sound like I'm
obsessed for a partner or that I think
that's the answer but I do think when
you have love and you're able to share
it with someone
and when you're able to compromise or
um just the different things that happen
in a partnership
I think that'd give me some
self-esteem that I'm able to
I'm able to uh become a person that I
don't think I can be
and maybe
um
I don't know
have you ever felt loved no not even as
a child no the father of your child
no I had no business being married I was
married at 28 and when I say I have no
business I was a very faithful woman
um
just I didn't have anything to provide I
didn't know about compromise I didn't
know any of these things it was my way
or the highway but it was his way or the
highway so it was just a cultural
difference I think of what happened in
the end but no
you know sometimes the filter that we
have can block you from being able to
accept love
certainly what happened to you when you
were a young girl with your dad can
create that block from feeling lovable
do you feel like that's what happened to
you
I I I think it's that I think it's my
mom my dad but I think it's it's uh the
constant
um
not reassurance the constant
when you realize over and over when you
try to love her you try to put yourself
out there in the constant Rejection it
just eats at you and it's only building
on a pile that you've already you've
already you already have this huge pile
and then it just adds to it and then so
it's like life experience it's it's not
just that stuff it's it's truth it's
going on dates with guys who say my
midsection is too fat or who
don't call me back
um or people I mean guys make comments
that just reiterate what I'm feeling so
it's not like I'm making this all up or
it's not like I had this bad childhood
and now things are great and everyone
says great things like it's only uh
solidifying what I already know but yeah
I could have
rose-colored glasses but I would say
that no one's ever tried to change it
being
in Texas makes it difficult
um
being in Texas so I'll move here next
year into la
here being in Texas
is
my son is there and I share custody
being there um
no I mean it's
the same everywhere I think
um the great thing about moving to La
will be that I feel like I'm a pack
person so my sister already has a family
and
um just she and her husband have a great
relationship and they just include me
and I feel like if that's my destiny
then maybe it'll be but
whenever there's major change so when my
son will go to college
um
I need somebody there and my plans don't
involve another person so I have to
start making plans for my future now so
my plan is to live with my sister and
her husband
and then they're gonna build a house in
Pismo Beach
and maybe I'll do that too in a couple
years like my plans are their plans
because I don't have the possibility of
or I don't have the luxury of making
plans with anybody else
certainly you're an attractive woman who
could
find a partner who
but you feel like your self-worth your
self-esteem is just so beaten down
not sure what repels people so much
because I feel like
certainly if I weren't here I wouldn't
be pouring all of this over someone so I
don't
I mean yes maybe you can pick up on it
and stuff but I feel like I can put a
pretty
funny front on and I'm funny and I'm
likable at times
so now
I don't know
that's the conundrum that's the problem
is
I want something that I don't think I
can ever have
I'll do
I'll be 46 in 20 days you're 46. you
look much younger thank you
but getting older as a female
exacerbates the problem right it does
and and when you're I had my son late so
um just that I'm gonna have a whole new
life I at 47. I have a whole new chapter
let's say I live to 100.
in in there I could potentially have
this whole new life or right now I'm
swallowing and stuck and thinking I'm
not gonna make it
you know many more years outside of when
he goes to college
but how does one make it without love
I don't think
so I don't believe in God whatever Force
there might be or maybe not be I just
don't think humans are meant to live by
themselves and alone
um I
look at couples even with my sister and
her husband
and I see just you know the little touch
or
smile across the room and I just don't
have that and I
but I'm so mad at how how I was raised
for
maybe if I were raised in a different
way I would have it do your sisters know
and understand what you went through do
they go through the same thing you think
they have different experiences not the
same
um we are just two years apart all four
of us so
um they have my sister right that lives
here
um her thing is more she tried to always
fit in to a popular crowd we had popular
and not popular kids and she always
tried and that's her big deal is she
always wanted to be something that she
wasn't we were from the wrong side of
the tracks and
um so that that's her her thing is all
about rejection and I while we lived a
lot of those same experiences
um
her her set of problems are unique to
her and then my other sister she sort of
just denies that she's had any problems
and she just goes through life
I'm not sure what goes on in her head As
She lays her head down at night but she
makes a pretty good front of not having
any issues
um my brother who is the oldest and who
remembers the most
from when they were together
um
he he's in a marriage
he's in our hometown as my mom
dad
and brother
uh they're they're there in my hometown
um
yeah I everybody has something my mom
had a great love who was my stepdad
um who died of cancer
he was the only man who ever loved me
and who I ever felt safe with
he picked me up at 16 from Texas
drove to Michigan on my spring break and
we had to stay in a hotel together
on the way back
I was terrified and my mom didn't know
about my dad until I was 18. until he
went to prison
I remember her waking me up and then I
told her it happened to me too
um
but yeah my step dad was the best once
we got through that hotel night
um I just begged my mom make sure
there's two beds like
terrified
um even I didn't know him well I didn't
know any of her boyfriends well but he
stuck around and until 2012 he passed
away
he
he was my great love
without
I don't know if that's right to say but
he was my great that person for me
and he's gone
so but I still feel him sometimes do you
feel lovable
yeah at times I felt very lovable no but
do you currently feel lovable
yeah kind of I mean looking at you you
certainly seem like an attractive woman
that could easily attract a partner
I and therein lies the problem I'm not
looking to play your therapist here I'm
not a therapist but well but just as a
person to have a conversation with yeah
and I see your problems
you you certainly look
but I'm not
you might say that or somebody on the
street or somebody watching this video
might say oh but you know she's full of
[__] because what
what's your problem but it has I don't
know I feel lovable some days I feel
like I could be the perfect partner I
could be fun and
um even just for friendship I feel like
I would be a good friend but I don't
have friends
do you think there's anything that you
do or are doing that might create that
with the friends I think I'm not very
good at like
um making plans and keeping them up like
when I want to do something I want them
to be available but I'm not always
available for I'm not available for the
emotional side that a friendship needs
um
yeah I have kind of a Don Rickles
personality so someone has to be very
open to me being like that and not
sending Emojis with my text to like say
haha I'm kidding so I think that might
keep people away
um
another thing I think I do is keep
weight on that I hate and it makes me
hate me and I keep it on and then
sometimes I think I think it's because I
know it repels people
that probably doesn't sound very good
because I'm not keeping a ton of weight
on but just so you know it's
uncomfortable for me yeah but I mean
there are even drugs now that
millions of women are taking that yeah
I'm not opposed my stir is on one
certainly not opposed
there's something in me that's kind of
like
if I keep that then at least there's a
reason why I'm not
being attracted or I'm not attractive to
people
um same thing with agent I can certainly
go get fillers and Botox and all that
stuff to make myself look
like everybody else but um I think
there's part of me that just keeps this
um I don't suggest any of those things
that we just talked about are the answer
I think your belief that you are
genuinely lovable how do I change it
I don't know you should have had a
different set of parents that's really
right and I think like of the comments
in the comment section
like people will say well I love you or
you are lovable you are pretty and it's
like that that I don't mean to be mean
but that doesn't
that won't help me there that doesn't
people can say I love you from afar but
and people can love just soul to solar
person to person but
as much as people can say all of that
that I'm lovable and or I'm beautiful
you're beautiful it's like
but you don't know me
right it almost requires something
profoundly deep to change your mm-hmm
your situation
I get that
yeah maybe I'll
find it um
and my plans won't be what my sister's
plans are you know what her husband's
gonna do upon retirement like those will
be my plans have you traveled the world
no see I think sometimes
traveling the world
even going to places that you're afraid
to go to
can sometimes just shake things up turn
a person's mindset upside down that
makes them somehow
open to
experiences and people and things that
might
change your life
have the heart to try her I don't have
that
oh you're coming to California and
that's that's a big change oh yeah oh
yeah and and it it actually is a
blessing and a curse that I have this
great neighborhood to stand because my
sister and her husband aren't people
about town they're very settled in their
lives and I come here and it's almost
even worse of a depression because
you're in the place of opportunity and
fun and the beach and I'm sitting day by
day
at their house and I want to do stuff
but I don't I thought I made friends in
treatment Because treatment was here
and the friends you make in treatment
are the most reliable
so
um but I mean like you're into music and
there's a certainly a very strong music
scene here in L.A am I going to go by
myself yes you are no
I can't
I would love to most people would
no I'm it's I have PTSD it's I have a
cptsd but
um that I don't know that I could handle
being by myself maybe I could I don't
what are you afraid of
people
um like rejection or or rejection
um
I'm scared just of safety which is uh
weird because I drove down here with
not a question of safety
um
yeah just
uh
it sort of sounds like I haven't found
myself as I'm speaking but
I don't think that's the case and drugs
have never been an issue for you no it's
good for you I'm very careful with
um
making sure I'm not addicted to anything
so I remember after I had my son I had
an episiotomy and they give you
hydrocodone and I remember liking it a
little too much so I am
I knew like I could I could possibly
have asked for another prescription but
no I I'm I have no vices which is also
probably one more thing that um I need
to get because people that have them no
you don't well people that have them
seem to be a lot happier
um I had one drink the other night
um out of a great restaurant and paid
for it the whole next day
um so drinking is not your thing either
I will drink
um and I I would say I'm fun after a
glass of wine loosens me up
um but it's it's the after effects now
as I get older that I don't want to you
know it's too much lose the whole day
yep
not that my days
are that meaningful
and your dad's in still in prisoners no
he's out I think he did about seven
years got out on parole went back for
violating it somehow but I'm not sure
are you angry
at my dad just angry angry at him or
anybody
I don't carry anger I've never been
angry you don't seem like an Angry Bird
I've never even yelled in in my life
[Music]
no I'm not an angry person at all I am I
am the kindest not the kindest I hate
when people say that I'm a kind person
you're a kind person I'm um I I fed
someone my um
my food from Saddle Peak lodge um at a
gas station the other day just I believe
that you're a kind person
anxiety I have a lot of anxiety
um and depression
yeah depression and I hate to label it
as depression I was just speaking with
my sister about this today it's
depression-like actions without the
feeling of constant sadness so it's
speaking about not living in like a nice
way
um but not having necessarily the the
sadness which I have had before but
right now I'm in a place where I don't
feel that but I feel
I feel so totally unused and unneeded
and I know my son needs me but I almost
feel sometimes like my son would
understand like with what I was given
like how could anybody have anything
else like how could my life be
successful when I was given this set of
circumstances
um I wouldn't know when I went to
treatment my ex-husband and his new wife
were very very caring and not caring
understanding but they said yeah
given her life like how could she not
end up at 45 in mental health facility
trying to get better
the one thing I will do though is take
shots I I took a shot here I took a shot
by going to treatment it takes
tremendous courage to just do what
you're doing right now yeah I mean I
thought for sure there would be
rejection I analyzed my video I you know
I
yeah I can't believe I'm here
um but I will sometimes get a hair and
take a take a shot
um well you're doing it now yeah and
I don't know what'll come from it
I'm hoping something does but I can't
imagine what would
um
sometimes it's good just to shake things
up and doing this could just do that
hey
regret it not regret it but just feel
the same I'll feel the same
yeah
I need to get back to Dallas because
while I'm here
like I said if there is nothing to do no
friends it's hard to get out and do the
things that are fun you know no but I
know people that are your age and older
who have a very active
life in the music scene or in other
scenes here in LA
I assume that probably exists in Dallas
and in many other cities in the country
but but in La I know it exists
and I hope you
you know take to something like that
I mean I'm not gonna just find friends
yes you will no I'm not
I tried dating here in La when I was in
treatment or right when I got out of
treatment when I was in the the
treatment was for
um just general mental health depression
I was overwhelmed at work and then my
son had a bad breakup his first
girlfriend
and he
I woke up to a text I never wake up in
the night but I woke up to attack so my
um my friend my son's a guitarist and
another band mom sent me a text and said
is Hudson with you in I ran the Hudson's
bedroom and
this is a kid who just got back from
Hawaii the same day and he got a new car
um and he was on the roof of my parking
garage at my Apartments
um saying he was going to kill himself
and recording himself and sending these
crazy manic text to his girlfriend
um
I don't play around with that stuff my
my child's not going to go through the
same life as me so
um
yeah so we got him treatment
for five days it turns out he never
really was going to but
um I processed that and was into mom
mode for about uh
a month and then I crashed
the one thing I love is
offering to take himself away from me
and what the hell am I gonna do if that
happens
the only choice would be to go too
but yeah
that's where all my love lies
hopefully I don't overwhelm them too
much with it
and it's a good thing he has his dad
who's much more conservative and kind of
balances out my free spiritedness
but that was what treatment was it was
um my my son is actually transgender
um
from male to female so for purposes here
I'm saying he it's just something that
we haven't gotten to yet of completely
changing pronouns
um
but
uh anyway the treatment was a lot of
like morning I have no issue with it but
just mourning the thought or the dreams
you have for a boy versus a girl
um and then yeah just realizing I had a
lot of grieving to do
um
but also that's when I just got pissed
off I was like [__] it [__] this how
I can't I was presented into the world
with nothing and then now some force is
Gonna Take It All Away the one thing I
have is that's gonna go away
was so mad
and I was mad at my mom I was mad at my
dad
um
mad at the situation
I never knew Hudson was never depressed
so
it was really a shock he decided to be
transgender after the breakup before
he considers himself a lesbian so it was
a girl
um
and you know as much as I'm very much
open and I think any parent would tell
you I'm open about it and accepting but
you're still mourn
um
you know my son's a rock star
you know Small Small Town rock star
um and seeing like thinking of dreams
dreams of going to Hollywood or dreams
of going to college and pursuing
um music and even just like music
production or or being on stage he's
gonna go more towards business but that
was all as a guy you know he's this
long-haired hippie kid much like me
um
looks wise not
not us
um but yeah my dreams were of a boy
um and a guy doing that and
um well I think
everybody's so accepting now so it's not
a big deal
um necessarily I do think it's easier
for guys in the music industry uh
so
we'll see he's very much still male
presenting some days female presenting
the other days just depends on his
outfits but like even when he would
perform I would style him and like that
was my joy as a boy so now
he uh we style him as a girl
what's your biggest fear now
my biggest fear is like not finding
having to in July when my lease is up of
next year moving here and having to move
in with my sister and
follow the path of
her husband's retirement and do what
they do
it's not a fear because it's what I
don't want to do I want something else
for my life
my biggest fear also is just things
leaving here and nothing changes
that'll be very disappointing for me
I don't know why it's not like coming
here and recording
that I think anything will change but
I don't know
I guess I thought maybe there would be
some aha moment here
or some feeling of uh accomplishment
Maybe
but
yeah
all I can suggest is what I've learned
which is courage seems to be the
solution to so many problems like this I
don't know what form that courage can
take but
what I've learned is courage is the
answer
you might know what form of that courage
might be appropriate but
I don't know yeah
I don't have the answers and you know
there's path as I probably would have
gone down and it'd be a more creative
field than what I'm in but once you get
into a field of corporate America I know
you left
but um you get used to a salary having
insurance and
um since I'm the breadwinner in my home
since I'm the only person and
um I can't just leave and make the same
amount that I'm making so you kind of
get stuck that would be my if you asked
me what it would be like a life-changing
thing right now would be to be able to
leave Corporate America for something
some kind of passion and that could be
the courage that but I can't do it
I can do it if I find somebody else that
takes away the burden of of
um bills and stuff luckily bills and
stuff aren't a burden for me but your
story is probably very relatable for a
lot of people I hope so that's I mean
that's the only thing I can the only
reason I came on one I guess I thought
maybe you had a bunch of magical answers
or being here would
spark some something in me but um yeah I
I don't know how relatable this is and I
don't know how I'll come off
but um
I I think there's so many people in
their houses right now
um wishing somebody would text them and
wishing and you might look at them on
the outside and think oh they have it
all or you know whatever
and we're all waiting for a text or
waiting for some physical touch I I
don't want to be hugged yet I want to be
hugged
um I'm maybe afraid that if someone hugs
me I'll fall into their arms Are You
Afraid Of Love
no I'm I'm a little bit afraid if I
would be capable of the traditional kind
of love where somebody's in your space
all the time
um are you afraid of having your heart
broken
yeah I am
I feel like
when I find the person
Something's Gonna click yeah that's
that's I really think that's gonna
happen
and then once I have that I think some
of the insecurities I've had in other
relationships will just go away
hopefully
um
yeah so
maybe that's
I'm not I don't know
I do think that there's something to
that like somebody initially I went on a
date the other night and
kind of 10 minutes and was like yeah the
initial spark thing isn't there you know
we'd probably be good friends
um
I was like really that we're having a
really good time but yeah I wasn't
necessarily there for me either
it's all difficult life is difficult
for a lot of people yeah
but I believe in miracles you do
I think I'll go to my grave
well that's great that you believe and I
wish I could believe in them too and I
do want to I see through Tick Tock and
Instagram all the time like
Friday July 7th is going to be the day
you're gonna get these great you know I
don't think I believe in that stuff so
Friday happened yesterday and I'm like I
don't know I don't know if that's the
face that Miracles what happened what
happened to Friday but I did get the
notification that I was coming here on
Friday
something else happened on Friday that I
thought was kind of cool
um but yeah so I sort of buy into that
stuff um or cn11 everywhere I sort of
bind to that stuff
um one thing I did want to say is that I
always feel like I have like a book in
me I don't I'm not going to pursue it
because I don't I don't think my story
is interesting enough for a book but
um I had somebody in my family say
well what would be the last chapter
you're single and alone and live in an
apartment like where is the crescendo
where's the happy ending
and maybe there won't be one
overall the authors of Our Own
stories
and lives
and
when has there ever been a great story
that didn't end with some kind of
courageous Act
yeah
I don't know
writing a book
yes you are I would be really good at it
I'm a writer that's our lives are books
yeah but pinning it down you know I
maybe could have a a funny maybe maybe
it's throwing your career away and
starting all over yeah in in what you
know like I don't have something to fall
back on that if it didn't work out or
that somebody else takes over that you
know what
for single moms I think that have been
single for so long and me for 14 years
I've had a couple of relationships have
never lived with anybody but
you almost just want somebody to come
take the weight that's on your shoulders
and just take it off
and that is freeing in itself like oh
just
oh I don't have to
do everything and be everything to
everybody like somebody else actually
wants to help
um and I'm not talking financially
um no but that's part of the equation in
general yeah just help and build you up
like that to me is such a foreign
concept
um I've been doing it by myself
um
for decades for decades for decades
a lot of decades
um yeah I mean I'll keep going
[Music]
you deserve love just like everyone does
you saying that is almost frustrating to
me because
I'm gonna walk out here without it
you can say it all day anybody can say
it all day anybody can say I'm beautiful
but I'm gonna walk out the same Buffy as
I walked in
just a little bit more relaxed
hmm mm-hmm
all right Buffy thank you for sharing
your story thank you